[...]
Imagine this thought experiment.
Everyone gathers in a great assembly
to vote on the principles that
will govern society.
But during the assembly,
everyone temporarily
forgets his or her social
and economic status.
You don't know your race, gender,
religion, ethnicity, or class.
You don't know whether you were rich
or poor, strong or weak, healthy
or unhealthy.
Under these conditions,
which of these principles
would you choose to govern
social and economic inequalities?
One-- permit only
those inequalities that
increase the overall welfare
of society, or total utility.
Two-- permit only
those inequalities that
benefit the least advantaged
members of society.
Or three-- permit whatever
inequalities result
when some people work hard and exercise
their talents more successfully
than others.